Georgiy go away I need to ask a favor
what it's private
can I come in come on what do you want
it occurs to me you have something in
common with Captain Kirk
we're both have cool hair in order to
succeed you both play fast and loose
with the rules yeah I supposed to Purdue
when you cheated on the math test what
was your strategy well I guess the most
important part was not stepping on
anything wet before the test and not
getting an A why wouldn't you want an A
cuz that would raise suspicions who'd
believe I got an A Wow tell me more okay
when you're telling a lie
it's important to throw in some details
like when I wanted to spend the night at
Ricky's house and mom asked me if his
mom and dad were gonna be home I said
not only are they gonna be home
his dad was gonna teach us how to cook
turkey legs in the smoker
I like turkey legs were they good there
weren't any turkey legs you dope his
parents were in Branson that's
incredible I totally believed you
details I get out of here I got to
finish reading this ooh that's rough hmm
how'd it happen it's hard to say but
some risk factors include heavy lifting
a chronic cough and repetitive straining
during bowel movements I've been there
all right guess I'll see you in six to
eight weeks
I don't know if other supervillains
started their careers by getting out of
PE but that's where I began emboldened
by my faux hernia I started taking books
out of the library without getting the
cards stamped you didn't check out those
books I know before you judge me too
harshly I always brought them back on
time now I was a rule breaker not a
lunatic but perhaps my most satisfying
transgression was duping my sister in to
relinquish 'uncle of the TV hello
where's that far oh this I was just
digging for money in the moss backyard
there's money there oh yes I already
found 75 cents who do you think left it
already guess I'd say pirates with holes
in their pockets can I use your shovel
be my guest
oh baby I'm gonna be rich
hello old friend
[Music]
you